you are listening to the hot breath
podcast I am your host comedian Joel
Byers and welcome to your weekly guide
to comedy mastery started or is it yeah
the podcast has started oh wow
I may look down at this periodically
just to make sure we're still rolling so
this is the beginning of the podcast a
little bit yeah it's like I always yeah
I'm never sure what's going on when it's
like I don't know when it started
because I feel like I have to I'm not
naturally like entertaining so I have to
like turn it on and then people still
can't tell what's the difference between
you turned on and turned off well I'm
not usually this high-energy if I just
had like eight red balls before I got
here yeah okay so this is live and then
will people be able to see the live
thing later or is it only for people
that are here it'll be on my page for
like forever ever I think forever for
Facebook
I don't think Facebook goes away oh wow
like edit out the weird awkward
beginning or no no I don't know when I
started alright it's fine let's do it
we're podcasting yeah we're - oh thanks
I have some martyrs as well Felix hot
breath water oh are you my man official
podcast water official podcast we're
educated escape so that's its Pontus
there are less professional just bring
water that's that's above and beyond for
podcasting yeah they do custom labels
and like coffee and all sorts of cool
stuff that's awesome so we we can
address the anxiety how do you normally
deal with your anxiety Oh work anxiety
how do I
would you say how do I deal with my
anxiety yeah cuz a lot of people suffer
from anxiety so what are ways you found
work best I think I don't know I just
try to notice it more now and try to
figure out what it it's coming from and
then deal with the thing like if it's
anxiety from me from something I'm not
facing I like I'm afraid to deal with
then I have to like just maybe think
about what that is and then try to
address it because yeah I think a lot of
anxiety comes from yeah either like
you're not facing something or you're
worrying too much about what people
think so those are like the big things
for me in terms of anxiety that I just
try to not worry about what people think
anymore
which is obviously not always the case
but yeah do you have anxiety as well not
not really but I know people that do and
it's it's not and I look could be
crippling for people yeah I think I've
gone through phases where it was kind of
crippling but I think I've like I'm in a
pretty good place now where it's at a
level that I can notice it and address
it and it doesn't really like take over
my life or anything but growing up I
certainly had like I'd say maybe at
times crippling anxiety or just you know
being really shy and overthinking things
and I still have a little bit of that
but I think I've learned recently how to
recognize it didn't deal with it and
I've definitely made some progress and
that helps there's a performer that you
learn how to communicate with people and
you can also kind of channel that into I
think hopefully being vulnerable on
stage and talking about those things
that you struggle with and so sometimes
like painful experiences you can get
hopefully a material out of and stuff
which is nice how do you address it you
represent a couple times what you like
if you're experiencing anxiety will you
then just reflect on it will you write
it down how do you actually address um
yeah I definitely try to write stuff
down like every morning I do like I
write a journal like three pages excuse
me and that's
something from this book the artists way
and it's just kind of like that yeah
yeah I love that book but the two things
they mostly took away from it we're like
writing three pages every morning
they're just kind of clear your head I
think that's helped me a ton and then
also like going on like a artist date
which is like just doing something for
fun for yourself once a week we're just
like you know kind of give yourself a
break and enjoy life and it kind of
recharges you and gets you it actually
ironically it kind of helps your work
but it's all about like not you know
taking a break from work mode and just
doing something for fun which actually
it makes you usually more productive in
the long run but it's just to be charged
and everything anyway sorry I don't know
this is supposed to be like a funny
podcaster no no last night oh yeah it
was like how I built this for comedians
yes so have you heard how I built it no
it's an NPR podcast okay where they
interview people who've like started
major companies and like Mark Cuban and
people like that and pretty much you
know who Mark Cuban is I've heard the
name people that I should know it's just
all about dissecting the commedia in
their process how they got to where they
are and the mistakes they made along the
way oh okay
if we want to like in thinking of
comedians and general anxiety is
something that a lot of comedians suffer
from so it's a good insight sure even
just even some people may cuz I think
you went through a phase where you may
almost would like puke before shows did
you go that oh yeah did I tell you that
did you just guess that I just know you
Jacob
have you been reading my yeah you still
feel like I was gonna throw up before
every show I was like like I said very
anxious in general so I was like I would
get a lot of nerves just you know about
talking to someone one-on-one or even
starting any conversation let alone you
know going up for a group of people the
first time I did stand-up for probably
six months or a year I would do it as
often as I could but every time I would
be terrified and I
be like have like feel like I was gonna
throw up and have like you know I don't
want to get too gross but I'd have I'd
have like nervous
diarrhea and Oh everything yeah yeah it
would come out what it was like
whichever way you gotta get out of here
because something terrifying is
happening out there
which was just me talking to people with
a microphone which is actually a pretty
safe setting physically but in my mind
was very very terrifying and it still is
to this day now I've been doing it like
coming up on 11 years in September so
now it's it gets a little less scary
over time but you can still eat channel
that nervousness now it's like not as
extreme but I can usually now channel
that into excitement even though if it
doesn't sound like I'm excited you know
I am secretly I'm excited but it doesn't
always show in my vocal branch that's
part of the charm though and you've
probably in think comedy that long and
that's you know I mean I've been doing
comedy with over eight years so I'm I'm
thinking more in like the PERT like more
self-awareness and trying to like
develop what like is my personality
onstage yeah writing is very important
but it's also now thinking of I have the
writing now how do I deliver it that's
true to me yeah I feel a strong delivery
and I've seen you do things like a rose
petal is like you crushed it was really
fun thanks I'm really good at writing
and performing but but yeah it's like
gonna be one I guess it's just you
figure it out more and more as you go
but especially by ears like you
definitely know what you're doing you're
very funny so appreciate it man it
wasn't that roast battle was not playing
enough to air but that's totally cool it
was cool I went up against that Dulce
Sloan who's now on The Daily Show
oh yeah she's really funny but our
segment didn't quite make it to Comedy
Central we got on the cutting room floor
I guess which is totally cool I'm in
hindsight I'm grateful that wasn't like
the TV debut so it was just a good
experience and a good opportunity to
perform under pressure you know oh for
sure yeah that was a fun show well when
you're in these pressure-filled shows do
you have a pre-show ritual that can kind
of help
quell the nerves yeah I know they say
that you're supposed to picture the
audience naked one time I lost my
glasses so I did that but it just looked
like everything was censored but anyway
no I guess pre-show rituals
I liked yeah no I don't know if for me
it just helps to like go over my set in
my head and practice what I'm gonna say
sometimes I did that I don't do that
enough and but that does out there just
listening to other sets and you know
just looking at the crowd and to kind of
see you know cuz I'll probably still do
the same jokes I was planning on but
then it's nice to know if it's like an
older crowd or whatever the situation is
and then you can at least be aware of
that so how about you do of like rituals
I I like to keep to myself like I
haven't no yeah I always have we're out
pretty much just I'll doodle or do like
set lists like the set list I want to do
and it's just something just to keep me
in my own space and why I'm there cuz I
have I've always been like that but the
few times I got a like a little
extroverted and hung out and like was
silly with everyone yeah I like didn't
have it for the stage
yeah I agree I think some of the yeah
the times I've done best a lot of times
it's like it's nice if I have the chance
to be alone ahead of time so I can
really think about it yeah and plan it
out and then once you're out there you
can deliver way you planned on but it is
hard sometimes switch from like social
mode into performing mode because you've
been in front of people but then it's
almost like that's you know taking some
of your performance power away because
you're like already entertaining people
and then you can't go into like I mean
I'm basically just saying less a
particular version of what you just say
but I agree yeah and everybody has a
different process that's why I love
stand-up is because it is an individual
sport
oh yeah like some people can be like
hang out and then just going to say
yeah I guess yeah I'm more of the let's
helps me if I'm like and alone before it
you know figure out what I'm gonna say
and then what's cool and watching you
like cuz I've seen I've seen you live
some but I got to see what cats cafe
here in Atlanta this past Tuesday oh
yeah which is one of the long it's been
going on over a decade now but just to
see that show can be especially like the
host was super hyped oh yeah you know
but then you go up there and you just
you go right into you go right into you
you don't even you don't kind of like
wait for like though the waves the cell
or anything you literally just go right
into your energy uh-huh and then and I
was like oh that was a little jarring
but then yeah they came to you like you
you kind of lulled them into your song
which was very fascinating to watch oh
thanks
yeah I mean I'd like to maybe that's
probably something I could work on is
like being more like you know adapting
more to the room because usually I do
pretty much stick to what I'm gonna do
but you do it yeah it does help to be
aware sometimes you have to like move
things around in the set or do a little
bit of riffing up top to get them so I
don't know for me like I just my
favorite part of Stan it was just like
telling the jokes I plan on but there's
definitely like weird situations
sometimes where you have to follow
something really intense and then but
yeah there's a fun show that was cool
but there's a confidence too sticking to
your notes because if you try to
replicate the comic before you then
that's not you and it doesn't come off
very well you just you were just you
like oh I'm just I'm trying to
compliment you on the confidence takes
to stick to what you were gonna do
regardless of what happened yeah it's
you could say it's either confidence or
just not having a ranch outside of the
thing I was fighting with you so that's
my only option but thank you I'll take
it are these people talking on Facebook
or what is I'm not sure what's going on
all the way
it may just be people who were showed up
and then left are people saying anything
yeah oh yeah someone asked did you say
nervous gonorrhoea and the answer is no
that was I might have mumbled that that
was diarrhea just I forgot this is being
recording it on like three platforms so
just to clarify that was diarrhea which
is gross but not in the same way as the
other one and then someone said I don't
know they wrote something else okay
we're mostly caught up what is the worst
you've ever bombed like fear been booed
on stage um
yeah I'm sure I have I did one show that
was like I got booed once though there
was this show on like a boat that was
like going to this Statue of Liberty and
back and then it was like there was a
comedy show but I don't think anyone
knew that there was gonna be one so for
that for like four hours everyone was
just like drinking and dancing and
eating and having a good time and then
so everyone's just like on a dance floor
and then I cut the music off so
everyone's like I already met but
there's no music and it's like four
hours and and then they're like all
right it's time for a comedy show so
then you're just like performing for
people that are just upset that you're
talking and they're talking and there
was like one guy like they were I guess
they were booing everyone on the show
but it was still it was pretty intense
when I was like the first time I had
been booed so like like I was like there
was this one guy that was booing and
like running towards me and then but
then he was just like stop and like do
another lap or something like he's like
I might as well get some cardio and yeah
it was weird cuz like there weren't
chairs so like it looks like kind of a
rap battle situation or something like
you're not supposed to be standing at
the it helps it feel air like sitting
down and anyway it was like a whole
weird show of the situation but but yeah
I don't know I've had yeah I've had
plenty of shows that didn't go
but that's I think that's part of comedy
is a lot of trial and error and then you
just see what works and what doesn't
work yeah and you sometimes it's just a
weird situation for comedy like I did a
show in a library and this guy called me
in the library and I'm like how much
does it pay he's like nothing I'm like
all right I'm in so I showed up yeah and
they were like two people in the
audience and when I got there which I'm
kind of exaggerating because one of them
had to leave to use a computer before
they introduced me so I was literally
like doing a show for one person in a
library and then like right when I
started like to librarians came in and
they're like hey it's 4:30 we're closing
so you have to wrap up the show so that
was like the first time I got heckled by
more people than there were in the
audience and as I can at least check out
a book on overcoming depression or
something but yeah that was a bit I just
I just did a bit the last part of the
bit is yeah I know I was hoping you
wouldn't call me out on it and it would
sound like an organic story but there's
a bit but it's also a true story is just
our bits allowed on this or absolutely
were like yeah you're great man
anything's allowed anyway
I felt I felt like I got away with doing
a comedy show and it plays like nice
must be talking but I feel like you
might have figured out is a bit because
we did a show yesterday where I probably
did that onstage I don't remember you
doing that I was just listening it was
just very clever so I assumed there was
yeah ever involved that's actually not a
bit I've just I found everything I say
just comes out like that really all
right
it was kind of like last night at my
show I was asking about Wilding out and
being the like I was like oh and you're
the white guy and you're like well I am
on there and I am here and I am
everybody like you had this whole like
rejoice why it's my ethnicity doesn't
like change based on the radiation I'm
at
did you is that a bit or no that was uh
those are real just reaction because I
figured you've been asked that so many
times know it might turn into a bit now
but I was such a new and first-time
reaction we found something there
and yeah because how you delivered it
was it's just it's the same as if you
were performing and that then you
started to like jar like when I like
asked you about being nervous and then
you were like yeah this is just my big
break or whatever what like your then
you started making fun of the show and I
was like there he is
there's Jacob because there's a reason
you're on wild and out for eight seasons
you know like there's there's some
you're like a sniper with it you know
it's very unassuming Thanks
no I appreciate that it's it's I feel
very lucky yeah be here after May it's
season it's it's super fun but it is
like yeah it's like a comedy so weird
cuz I feel like I mean I've been doing
it a while and it's still like even
eight seasons and I never feel like
totally like it's not like ever a time
where I can like coast cuz it's still
like you kind of I don't you just don't
know what's gonna happen which I kind of
like the excitement of like I can still
say something and like I have no idea
how it's gonna go like it might luckily
you know if something doesn't go that
well they usually edit it out and just
keeping the stuff that works so you just
gotta try stuff out and sometimes it
works and sometimes it doesn't so it's I
like that it's like you're never totally
comfortable and there's always like that
element of like I think this is funny
but maybe the crowd will love it or
maybe they won't how prepared are like
the bits on the show um it depends like
we've been rehearsing the games and
stuff but then usually once we tape it's
like totally different just based on
what they choose for that day so the
rehearsals help us like get in that mode
of like coming up with stuff on the fly
but on the actual show it's basically
improvised and then you know sometimes
you can look and see who's on the team
and like try to I think or something but
then they might say something to you
first that like throws it all off so you
just kind of have to be like ready for
whatever yeah because you have an improv
background from doing comedy in a
Chicago right yes I did a bunch of
improv classes there and everything so
that helped I think with a wild and out
cuz you have to like basically I'm
providing stuff which is fun because
it's like a different muscle than stand
up so I like that I get to do both and
yeah I don't know I guess stand-ups and
improvisers are usually like rivals and
make fun of each other apparently yeah I
love I like doing both of them and yeah
and Atlanta's like Chicago and that
there's there's a big improv scene and
there's a big stand-up scene yeah
definitely I like yeah I've done some
improvements I'm stand-up here so far
and I like that they have a lot of
places for both it seems like they're
both really cool communities in town so
that's good yeah I like to think it
Lana's up next that's what we're
thinking like Chicago I feel like is on
right now with people like lil rel at
the helm of comedy and things but I feel
like Atlanta's the maybe the next in
line yeah I mean I think all of those
places are in the mix there's like yeah
super funny of people out of here in
Chicago and just know it is like yeah
all over there's a lot of good comedy
scenes right now which is really good
but you can always be the Beloit you can
always say you were the finest
technically started in Beloit Wisconsin
in college was the first place so what
was that experience like it was pretty
good let me see what this Pierce oh I
thought you were leaving I was like oh
no we brought a Beloit he's leaving
someone said they're naming their next
album nervous gonorrhea alright we're
all caught up so so Beloit Wisconsin
there's a small town on the border of
Illinois and I like that my biggest
laugh on this I got so far was from
reading that person's hashtag nervous
gonorrhea that's gonna be merged will
have Murch yeah well we're gonna have it
on the water bottles yeah it's gonna
want to drink out of that but this is
already
is it tangling up that's alright it's so
Beloit what was your first show like
there
I had a friend those like starting out
doing comedy and I said that was the
first time I saw someone starting from
scratch and not like a professional I
was I go he's doing it I might as well
give it a shot so I like told all of my
friends I was gonna do comedy at this
open mic and then I got really scared
and I probably would have backed out
except then they like showed up right so
I was peer pressured into sticking with
it and it was like a fight or flight
situation where like I was gonna be if
it didn't go well I would be like known
as the guy that bombed and was
humiliated like 13 yeah you know how do
you know okay
oh you do research okay yeah it's
written down do you wanna see it
no no because I went to a small liberal
arts school like that too yeah so I
understand that environment but I know
some comedy until second semester of
senior year when I just had nothing to
lose oh so I just went how when did you
do it I started like ready when I
started as a freshman at the beginning
of college he became that guy he became
the comedian on campus yeah I guess I
was like because it was such a small
school I was like the only comedian
there was also an improv group that I
tried out for and I did not I succeeded
in getting cast in it but uh but it's
okay but I got to do but there's some
funny people in that and then yeah most
of the college I was just like doing
open mics and trying to figure it out
this is probably I think you've done the
most research and it was done that's
interviewed me I've never heard someone
that new first of all the of Blois it
was found some let alone how many
students were there yes that's true yeah
I was on the track team so they had the
turtles on there which like I know they
say slow and steady wins the race but it
doesn't and do the bit well yeah you
know it's
I feel really I can't do them if you
know there are bigots but if they're
good bits you don't mind hear them you
know like yeah good but I feel like it's
in an interview it's like you're not
supposed to do bits unless it's organic
like sounding like it's part of the
right conversation that's true it's like
it sounds like I'm trying too hard or
something if I do material but if you
don't know its material then you're like
oh that was funny for like a spontaneous
conversation but then if you know it's
material then I really go that's like
kind of weird
he's just reciting another fun fact I
know about you that may make you nervous
is that you weren't really allowed to
watch TV growing up Wow yeah so well
what was the what was the home
environment like um my parents are both
kind of chill I was really in terms of
some in some ways in terms of maybe they
chose the wrong word but the reason I
would didn't watch a lot of TV it was
because my parents kind of believed in
the Rudolf Steiner philosophy of the
Waldorf schools which is like this
school where you kind of limit TV time
and you kind of focus on developmental
style learning where you like learn to
read a little later and stuff in the
ideas that like you do stuff because
you're passionate about it and you enjoy
it so you're not kind of like forced as
much to like memorize stuff or whatever
but it's more about just like learning
how to get into learning from in a place
where you're excited about it so even
like like the math classes and stuff
they tell stories there's a lot of like
fairy tales as a you know in the lower
grades and stuff and so interesting they
kind of get you into it that way and
where you're like entertained or kind of
passionate about it hopefully the
earliest that's like the goal of it I
think so then it's like you find the
stuff you gravitate to and that you want
to do not because like they're making
you do it because like you you know get
a chance to do stuff as like
experientially
kind of like building a shed or like
some of that more practical stuff mixed
in with the other kind of reading
writing and basic math and whatever like
a liberal arts approach I guess yeah
it's kind of like a little bridge
approach for younger kids yeah which
sounds like really pretentious
apparently but it was a good experience
like but uh but yeah it was a good great
school experience and then I don't know
yeah so that was that's my grade school
let's see who those are more let's go to
the comments let's go to the comments it
only shows two things at a time all it
says is that someone is watching bring
them on camera I don't know what that
means I'm not sure either anyway but hey
thanks for watching so what did you
gravitate towards when when you were a
kid um I guess I definitely got really
into like reading and writing and
storytelling and I would like write
short stories for my friends and then I
had a lot of free time as a kid only
choice I was an only child and my
parents weren't super social but so
there's like that were you get it from
yeah so there yeah I think both my
parents have stuff maybe some forms of
anxiety and I probably got a little bit
of that from them but I think I also
learned a lot of constructive stuff from
them in terms of I don't know just like
having a lot of free time did help me
like maybe figure out that I wanted to
do something with entertainment or
whatever and so I didn't know it was
gonna be comedy necessarily but I would
like always want to make sure movies
growing up and things like that and so
it's kind of fun now to get to do comedy
on show business type stuff because that
was always like something I was
interested in growing up and they do my
dad's a social worker and my mom's a
teacher so oh yeah yeah so it's pretty
different than what I do in some ways
but I think they both found something
that they
we're passionate about that like you
know they just like doing everyday and I
think I've found something too even
though it's a totally different field
and everything hmm
and so yeah I feel definitely lucky to
get to do comedy and it's the best yeah
it's so much fun it's the best
definitely you're doing great man
oh thanks doing great oh thanks well
here here you're doing great but then
also just in your career like it's uh
well how I called you like the the
silent assassin in person and with your
with your rapport but also like your
career like your you've done a lot and
it's all seeming like you're all just
kind of like very unassuming
but then when people look at your resume
they're like wait he did wait what whoa
what he's only been doing it like a
little over ten years it's very
impressive like the trajectory of your
career and oh well that's very kind
thank you I'm just trying to figure it
all out
and it's always everything is still a
mystery to me I feel like I feel like
I've just gotten lucky a few times and
stumbled into this stuff and but yeah
it's like anything you just keep doing
it and I think good stuff happens if you
just keep at it and there's always ups
and downs but overall yeah I feel lucky
that I've gotten to do some fun stuff
and yeah it's the best job that I could
imagine having so I feel definitely
lucky to get to do comedy and I mean I
don't know if luck luck would be the
right word but you've had some really
pretty like almost like predestined
experiences that have really taken your
career up levels even just the America's
Got Talent
you all the way from your doing a talent
show in college that then gets you to
open up for Nick Cannon which then leads
to America's Got Talent
right that means leaves like what like
it's just every step of the way it seems
like there's always been something there
that keeps you propelling yeah I
definitely never know what to expect and
I'm sure at some point you know I always
like assume
thing might go wrong in a month like it
feels like there's no stability in
economy but yeah I feel lucky that I've
had like some good experiences and yeah
they got to like open up for Nick and
when I win this contest
in college and that was a really good
experience and then I guess from there
on America's Got Talent he asked me to
audition for a while now and that was
that was definitely an exciting moment
for me and and scary because it was like
after America's Got Talent I was pretty
like depressed for a while and kind of
bummed out about just goes like I didn't
do as well as I wanted in my last round
and I was like feeling like kind of
disappointed in myself and then I was
like oh maybe I'm like you know maybe I
suck initially like quit comedy I was in
a pretty dark place and so then yeah I
mean one thing that externally I mean
hopefully I got myself out of it a
little bit but it certainly helped to
also like in it kind of a dark moment of
my life to hear someone ask me to
audition for something and then to get
to do it
and still be doing it later it's like it
was very surreal because it was like I
had no idea like the show was coming
back or that and I would even I didn't
have an agent or anything and so I just
all you yeah I mean I haven't yeah I
haven't really had a manager for most of
the time I've done comedy I have Morton
at the moment that I got recently but a
lot of this stuff has just happened from
I feel like if you just keep you know
keep getting onstage and keep just doing
what you think is funny good stuff will
happen and there's always you know ups
and downs of trial and error but but
yeah I definitely feel lucky that you
know it's I've gotten to do stuff from
just being around and just yeah I think
a lot of it is like you know it's not
like I'm naturally the funniest person
over but if you just keep showing up and
keep writing and getting on stage
hopefully think it pays off at least I'm
very happy with whatever results I've
had from doing that so
yeah if it's been fun it's so funny like
you make this big appearance on
America's Got Talent you make you make
it all over this semi-finals
yes in the semi-final say I think I
performed like four times over on you
you do great you have millions of views
but yet you're like oh no yeah I guess I
wish I had I think it yeah like if I was
on a show like that now I think if it
didn't work out I would I would be a
little more mature about it and be able
to move on quicker but at the time it
was like I had like nothing going on and
then that and then that was like my
first big exciting thing and then also
one of my first big like disappointments
at the same time cuz yeah there were
like really fun moments about it where I
was getting like standing ovations and
stuff and then there was like you know
parts where it didn't go how I wanted
and that at the time I took everything
really personally you know that stuff I
think I'm able to like not be quite as
phase now so back then it's like I could
read like I mean YouTube comment and
then like depressed for days and now
it's like there's so many YouTube
comments like I don't really read them
or if I do I don't take them personally
because it's like it's just eventually I
think you just kind of got calluses or
like like you have to still be sensitive
I think to be aware of like what's you
know you want to be listening to
audience but you don't have to like take
everything like where it's gonna like
affect you and ruin your day or or give
you like an inflated ego either you know
so it's like yeah I guess I just try to
pay attention there like overall like
you know cuz you do one showed where
it's like a tough crowd and and then one
show where it's a great crowd and you
can't really rely too much on either
because you have to like in your brain
be like okay that worked but maybe
they're laughing more than usual or less
than usual and then you just yeah yeah
yeah I just figure out of adjust to each
thing and that was like three years in
right like the America's Got Talent like
it was it was pretty early I had been
doing stand-up for about five years but
I was like four of those I was in
college so it was like he'd the
equivalent of maybe a lot less time than
not just cuz it was like
sometimes I could only do an open mic
every couple of weeks or something so in
reality I was like probably much less
progressed so I yeah it was like kind of
surreal to be going from like you know
struggling with day jobs and you know
doing mostly probably open mics at the
time and some stuff on the road but it
was like I was still certainly figuring
things out and with that show it's not
always like you know the funniest person
but I think for whatever reason they
responded to me maybe as like a part of
its casting and what story you have so
they could be like oh here's this nerdy
real-estate guy cuz I happen to have a
part-time real estate job for like three
months so they could it just gave them
an angle to be like you know like make
it seem like I had never done comedy
before and then that's like entertaining
for TV so it's not necessarily like this
is the funniest comedian but it's like a
funny like surprise if I'm decent I come
here giving that the audience thinks
that I've never done it based on how the
first one was edited well it was just I
only mean that in terms of how they
presented it with like like I come in
and like it looks like I'm like this
real estate guy that's like never done
standing in the interview and then I
don't know I probably shouldn't say too
much because the whole non-disclosure
stuff they have but but yeah it's they
obviously they do like to play up the
drama and stuff which is makes it it's
just you know part of why that shows
succeeds is because they know how to
tell stories and so it doesn't always
necessarily work in your favor but it's
like a good opportunity I guess if for
exposure which is nice you hear that
reality shows where somebody may say I
hate spinach and then later on they say
John and then they'll cut together and
this John yeah like you know so it's
yeah like there's this one time where I
think they had me say like I had drink
water when I'm nervous and then they cut
to this shot that I didn't know about of
me just like chugging it looks like I'm
like yeah let's see what they're saying
other more comments it says
oh wow this one is so long I actually
have to click the see more what is this
I think he's like roasting me maybe
didn't he lose out and the semi-finals
to that kid that can dig tunnels in sand
using only his teeth and eyelids I don't
remember who it was very possible I
think I did have to follow like a
parakeet that was like flying through
the audience which is the other weird
thing about that show because normally
you're like oh I have to follow like a
high-energy guy or something but then
there it's like oh no it's gonna be like
a kid doing backflips and like a dog
that's like jumping through hoops on top
of the audience or something so then
some of that stuff you just can't
compete with as a human let alone it's
like you know struggling comedian always
but it was a good learning experience
and yeah actually I mean in some ways it
was like I couldn't have wished very
better just even that it led to wild now
which has been so much fun is like I
guess I'm actually pretty lucky in terms
of there's no guarantees but leading to
anything so the fact that I've gotten to
do a fun other show from that is which
probably wouldn't have happened
otherwise you know anyway I feel very
lucky for sure yeah I've got a tip my
cap to your Colbert performance as well
oh thanks there was another thing where
as I was just performing at a comedy
club I didn't know anyone from there was
an audience but someone I didn't have an
agent or anything at the time and
someone just came up to me afterwards
and gave me a card and was you know the
one of the Booker's for that this she's
very proactive about finding people in
the scene she's great yeah so yeah she's
the best so I got really lucky that she
you know without having reps or anything
she saw me and saw something that she
was able to give me that kind of
opportunity so I think it's great that
yeah people do that and it's not always
like it's not just about connections but
if you just keep putting yourself out
there I can definitely lead to
good opportunities for sure that's a
good lesson and just focusing on being
funny and you've kind of referenced that
and just things have just happened
because you're just performing and
someone saw you and it's you're just
doing what you were supposed to do not
worrying about what other people were
doing and that's when you've gotten your
opportunities it seems yeah it's
definitely one of those things where you
never know what's gonna have it like
everything that's happened
good or bad like I couldn't really
planned it out or predicted it and but
yeah the thing is like yeah when things
haven't gone as well it's usually
because like I maybe took something for
granted or I thought maybe no one
important was an audience or whatever it
was and I think I've learned that it's
like I mean as a comedian it's like the
audience is your boss and really as long
as you're making them happy that's all
you have to do so it's not like you have
any one boss but you should be trying to
make the audience laugh and if you do
that then you're doing your job and it's
gonna pay off and like you're just gonna
get seen you know it's just gonna happen
like so it's like pretty I think it's
pretty simple as much as it seems like
how do I like some people here like how
do I get an agent or whatever like all
that just happens is naturally like if
you're you know funny enough to that
crowd enough fair enough crowds or
whatever like it just pays off and if it
doesn't work one night maybe it'll work
the next night it's like is performing
the same in front of two people that you
would 200 like delivering it like the
show matters even if it is seven people
on a Tuesday yeah for sure when your
manager did here he approached you
I'm guessing um yeah that was pretty
recent I started working with him and I
guess I had met him through my roommate
who works with him and there's also a
comedian
and so I guess it helps that I was got
to know him a little bit but but yeah
that was another thing where yeah I feel
like you want a manager that like wants
to work with you and stuff so it's like
I think it's definitely good to wait
until someone you know it's that's
always the best case scenario
I think I've had like two managers total
including the one I just started working
with and I've also been on my own a lot
of the time before and after that but or
not after that but but yeah so like in
between and I do feel like it's one of
those things where you still have to
like do a lot of things on your own but
but if you have a the right manager that
can help a lot and they can just help
give you opportunities and then you
still have to kind of make the most of
those but it's always works best when
it's like someone that wants to work
with you so it's not like you know if
you're just like submitting and stuff it
you know it might be something where if
you force it too much they might not it
may not actually be the right situation
I don't know anyway it was more force um
no I don't think so
I the first manager I had also actually
came to me and timing it like a wild and
out premiere party and came and wanted
to work with me and I'd never worked
with one before and so that was actually
and so I started I started working with
them and I think it was a overall was
like a really good experience and I
ended up I decided to leave them later
but but I definitely am still very like
friendly with them and you know at the
time I just felt like I wanted to like
do things on my own
and yeah it's like anything where you
know it's like friendships or
relationships where sometimes it's just
like the place in your life that you're
at or whatever you just kind of figure
out who's the right fit at the time or
if you want to like do it on your own
you know so yeah I don't know I feel
like I don't know I feel like I'm really
boring right now but no it's very
interesting yeah it's totally on topic
for the podcast because that's a world a
lot of people aren't familiar with it
can be intimidating or people can hold
up having representation to a higher
standard than maybe yeah because you've
gotten most your stuff just from being
around
funny as opposed to having someone get
it for you you know um
yeah definitely yeah I mean like I said
like America's Got Talent wild and out
Colbert we're all basically rose-petal I
guess it was all like kind of through
just being around her and not really a
through management and those have been
really exciting things
my first managers did help me get on
Adam Devine's house party and that was a
really good experience as well in
central yeah so it's definitely like
managers can be really helpful in some
ways like that but but yeah the vast
majority of things didn't like gigs and
stuff I've done a lot of it is like just
showing up and sometimes they were like
this person cancelled and we need
comedians or like if you're just there
enough they're like oh we should book
this guy and so yeah I feel like a lot
of it just comes out of just hanging out
at comedy clubs and you make friendships
and stuff and then comedians really help
each other a lot you know it just
naturally happens when like when they
have opportunities they can share with
each other so it's like
as much as it's competitive it's also
like I feel like a very collaborative
community where you know if you're like
performing somewhere you want to work
with people you like so you're like oh
this guy I know is really funny and then
you can get them to perform there with
you or whatever it is and then hopefully
that continues as you know I haven't
gone on to like do my own show or
anything but it seems like but you know
when people are at that level it's like
they definitely remember those people
that they met just hanging out at clubs
and shows and then those relationships
can definitely pay off in terms of
building stuff together and learning
like what kind of people you like to
work with and everything yeah I've done
over a hundred and thirty-five of these
and the most common thing I've heard is
like the people you meet are gonna have
your network is what's going to get you
most of your opportunities like just the
people you know and grew up with and
started with like some I'll get a TV
show and then they need a writer or they
enjoy like this seems to be kind of
focusing I think the theme is just
focus on getting funny first and then
worry about whatever sort of accolades
yeah for sure
absolutely and definitely yeah I feel
like those are the biggest things are
just like being funny and just being a
nice person I guess so being a nice
person it's like you might be rude to
someone because you don't care or
something and then maybe ten years later
they're like a big deal and you're like
oh wow I really wish I was on better
terms with them or whatever that
happened no not really
maybe no I don't know I do I do
I was just like saying hypothetically no
I guess no I do feel like I've learned a
lot through like trial they're like yeah
I do feel like it's important just to
like like there's no reason to like talk
[ __ ] or whatever outside of maybe like
your close friend or like lovers or
whatever but uh but yeah in general it's
like I don't know like you don't want to
be that person that's like just focusing
on the negative or whatever and because
anyway so yeah I try to focus instead of
like why isn't this working I try to
focus on oh why is this working focusing
on following your successes yeah it's a
good positive momentum and I think it
yeah and also even yeah just being happy
for people I feel like it just makes you
it gives you so much more energy like it
you can kind of use every good thing
that happens to other comedians as like
inspiration in a way to be like oh
that's awesome that he's doing that and
then you know I'm doing this other thing
but it's like it's inspirational as
opposed to like I don't know I guess an
artist way that they say like jealousy
is a map so it's like you can be like oh
that's cool that is doing that and
transfer that into like like what do I
want to do like what are my goals and
stuff and as opposed to like oh you know
[ __ ] that guy I figured that he had this
thing that I don't think he deserves or
whatever but uh but yeah I feel like
that's you know I just hopes this is
kind of corny but when like phrase I
think about a lot is just like that I
read on like it was like on a like a
motivational poster and a green room
wall of like a college show I was doing
one time and it was something like you
can't have a good day with a bad
attitude and you can't have a bad day
with a good attitude and it sounds like
really kind of corny but I as like a
really like logic driven person I kind
of like started thinking about it and
it's usually like come true for me if I
was if I've been able to like you know
not that like everything good throughout
the day everything's gonna be good or
anything but I feel like if you have the
right mindset
whatever happens like you're ready to
like make the most of it or bounce back
or like work around it or or take
advantage of good opportunities or see
opportunities that you wouldn't have
seen if you just are in a good place at
the time anyway so that's something I
think about it sometimes
it seems like that could play into your
psychology degree maybe what you've
learned from well you know so much about
I'm just I thought you'd feel honored
that no it's just funny that you say it
like as if everyone knows that I have a
psychology degree but like you're the
only person that knows that until unless
I've already told them now they know
okay well no hot breath averse nose yeah
so I just figured especially with you
having anxiety but then also stand-up is
a very it could be a psychologically
driven profession as well
yeah for sure I guess psychology does
help in terms of thinking about how
human behavior works you want to
recapture that onstage and talk about
real things and understand whether the
audience is thinking and feeling or
whatever and yeah so psychology that was
what I got my degree in and
I guess it's it was fun to learn about
it was something I was interested in
and then I started doing stand-up where
you don't really need a degree right
yeah but I guess it was good whose
interesting stuff because that's where
like you said pre-show you'll look at
the makeup of the audience to see who's
in it are there any other things where
you kind of analyze the the room in that
way um yeah I guess so yeah I did you
try to like listen to the crowd
and tell what they're going through and
you do want to like be in the moment and
so even though I do a lot of
pre-prepared jokes I wanted to you my
goal is always to be like myself and be
working in a clean stage so yeah I don't
know I got psychology of my factor and
with that how about you what do you what
did you yeah I try to keep into account
like what time is it what day is it
yeah what is the makeup of the audience
sure what are they louder they wearing
makeup in general yeah because if it's a
Tuesday in front of seven people in a
bar and do they have makeup on exactly
did you what did you it wasn't it wasn't
that thing I said wasn't that funny but
I repeated it anyway he says I was like
maybe if I say it a second or third time
okay so it's like when you look at an
audience you want to ask yourself what's
the makeup of the crowd and what's the
makeup the crowd's wearing in addition
to the makeup of the group the makeup on
their faces also psychology peeps
psychology what did you major in this
certain thing or I did organizational
management organizational management so
that's like when you're in an
organization it's like you're yeah
you're like being learning how to be a
manager in a corporation kind of thing
yeah and you also get into like like
Maslow's hierarchy of needs and like the
psychology of a corporation that is very
psychology but it's it's like those so
what's the I knew I probably learn this
but I've
what are the hierarchy of needs it's
like food oh I really don't know okay
literally like I had forgotten about
that until I mentioned the
organizational management and I was like
well what did I learn and I just
remember that being a slide in a
PowerPoint at some 8 a.m. class I have
no idea what it is
I don't know I don't remember guys if
you're commenting on this please Google
Manzo's hierarchy of needs and let us
know yeah answers we do need answers but
that was so it's like I'm not really
using it I am in I guess show business
so you do use business in that way but
it's not like I mean you got the water
bottles that's pretty organized and well
we'll get you out of here I know you've
been I'm not gonna get out here this I'm
staying in this place
oh yeah this is your suite actually so
so I'm gonna have to get out of here but
one thing I did want to dive into a
little bit yeah was your cool dive into
this shark tank you want to do a
read-along I just made me think of
diving because there's an underwater
yeah yeah we can really I mean yeah we
can read the whole thing if you want
we'll do that that'll be a bonus feature
to have a special password to log in and
see the full video yes so Colbert and it
was cool to know you got it from just
being funny in a club and in the book or
seeing you but in preparation for
Colbert what what was it how meticulous
was it like how many times did you rep
the set like really take us through okay
I'm gonna be on Colbert now what okay um
yeah it was pretty surreal it was
definitely different than what I would
have expected and for me I'd gotten to
do some other TV already so it was like
nice to have that experience I think
first but it was like a show that I
always grew up like watching The Late
Show and stuff when it was Letterman and
everything
and I just thought that was a really
cool space and a fun show and so it was
definitely like a dream come true to get
to do it but basically the process
leading up to it was I don't know it's
kind of a long process because it was
like there was a lot of time where like
you know I think they have to get it
approved by different people but one day
I think I just got an email that they
were like hey we like this video we want
you to do it and I think they made a
couple adjustments so I did like a new
video with the adjustments taken into
consideration and just shot that with a
new crowd but basically yeah I had a
video
I guess they liked it I don't know it's
pretty simple they saw me at a club and
enjoyed it and then we're like send me a
video I sent them a video five-minute
video yeah it was maybe six or seven
yeah something like that maybe like six
and then it got cut down closer to five
because they took out a couple things
maybe but it wasn't like a huge notes
process although other shows I've heard
do you have more because I think they I
guess they are pretty on board with
stuff I guess it just depends on the
specific set they see cuz sometimes it's
like ready for TV and then other times
there's like things that you might have
to take it out if it's like a brand name
or whatever right it might be really
funny but it doesn't work for their show
or in the voice you know but yeah it was
pretty for me yeah it was pretty
straightforward so then they're like we
want you to do it and so then I just
once I knew what they wanted I practiced
it a bunch and then I don't know it was
a little weird too because I had to like
almost reteach myself how to do it some
of the jokes I had to stop doing because
I I guess by the time I heard back from
them it was like kind of a video already
from a while ago and then I was like
kind of working on other newer material
stuff but then when I got the call it
was like that they wanted that it was
like I definitely ran into a bunch just
to like be like oh okay I guess that
doesn't work like it was it was kind of
weird because like
yeah sometimes it's hard to get stuff
approved in this case it was like
approved but then I was like I had to be
like I had to remind myself that this
joke I guess it's funny cuz it was like
some of this stuff was stuff that I had
been like I'd stopped doing because I
was like I don't know if it's fits here
but then yeah once they gave me the
notes I was like okay I guess yeah that
makes sense and so I don't know the
notes are like we like this joke but
take out this tag to it um I don't
remember actually but basically I think
there's just maybe a couple of things
that they thought like wouldn't work for
whatever reason or were to like either
like too dark or too you know not the
right fit for the show and then maybe
they rearranged a couple of things cuz
I'd actually sent them like a clip out
of like a longer set and so yeah so we
just rearranged it so like have more of
like a little bit of a more of an arc
even even though it wasn't originally I
actually wasn't performing it that way
because I was doing a longer set but
then when they asked for a video I'm
like oh I have this one and I actually
thought it would be a lot longer process
in some ways just because I figured we'd
go the you know through a few but I
guess it was basically just the two
videos but over a long span of time and
so that's when yeah we kind of figured
out what we agreed on for the set and
then yeah it was a fun experience
getting to be in that space and shooting
there and a fun crowd fund set up and
everything so you have to type do you
have to type in I've heard some shows
they make you tighten your set word for
word yeah I just send them like a
transcript so I guess that's helps them
in terms of like just getting it past
the censors and making sure it's not
offensive and then I had like a set list
on the teleprompter and so that even
though I'd run it a lot once you get up
there it is like a different situation I
feel like cuz there's a lot going on
with cameras and lights and stuff even
though they have that at other shows
it's like a little hectic so it does
help to like have that to go to even
though you already know it
to be like the transcript is a touch so
have that transcription but I had like
bullet point it's kind of like you'd
have a note with a setlist right right
so even though I knew it I could like
always remind myself because it was like
pretty specific more so than like at a
live show you can kind of like say
whatever you remember and then if you
forget something like it doesn't really
matter or you can just make fun of it if
you make a mistake yeah it's like if you
don't want to like get them in trouble
or everything so you just want to like
stick to what you got but uh yeah I
don't know I was like yeah it's a great
experience I've always wanted to do one
of those like late nights out so it's
nice to get to do that and would you
also like rehearse at home or like while
you're in commute like I did my
girlfriend at the time was riding there
with me I ran it past her a bunch of
times
mm-hm and so she was probably really
sick of it by this cuz it's just me just
saying it to her one-on-one and be like
okay now like try to not laugh I'll try
to make you laugh and like different
things like that which but ya know I'd
run it faster and run a fast other
people like friends over the phone and
different types of crowds and yeah I
don't know it's like you just it's like
just burning it into your brain almost
yeah and yeah I feel like that can help
but it's also like it's probably not
totally necessary to always go too crazy
with that because it's like you want to
sound organic and real and everything
because I think I have had things before
where I like over rehearse things and
then I was like - it sounded like too
much like I was reciting when I did
though so yeah I think you just have to
find the right balance of yeah being
like in the moment and also you know
doing what remember no want to say are
you in the green room like pacing and
going over it like rehearsing um yeah it
was definitely like thinking about it I
think it does help me to pace around and
think about it run it in my head or
whatever but I don't always necessarily
do that for regular shows but for that
kind of thing
I do think it's important to really
practice as much as you can
like figure out the beats that you want
and everything yeah I don't I mean I
don't normally do that for like an open
mic but if I'm like trying to tape a new
tape or something even at that level of
just yeah I want to get a new tape this
isn't even television it's like I am
that can be stressful too though because
it's like you like you want it to be at
the level of television the live tape so
that you know if they see that they'll
be like we should put this on TV
slightly even if it's not an actual TV
taping it's it can be as stressful I
think yeah because it's like oh this is
what determines if I get on TV if I do
well in this show which they saw us
eight you had taped that they were like
oh that would be good for TV and so it
translating oh yeah so it worked out and
it's funny because I was I was trying to
tape like a longer set for a different
thing and which you know and then so
it's just kind of funny how that happens
like sometimes you tape something for
one thing and then it might lead to
something totally different which you
know you just never know what's gonna
happen and your joke writing is so quick
it's like it's like boom boom and you
move on and boom boom and you move on
it's like the editing process must be
something you really focus on with word
economy yeah I mean I think everyone you
have to play to your strengths and some
people are like have way more range as a
performer and do it like awesome act
outs which I don't you know I'm not like
this super high-energy guy that's like
bouncing around making fun of people or
whatever but so that's why I I try to do
whatever I can you know which is not
those things so if I am like okay if I
can't do that then I guess I'll just you
just have to play to your strengths and
so for me I guess that's maybe it is
some of the editing and just like
figuring out the wording and then also
like figuring out my own way to deliver
things even if it's not gonna be this
like super charismatic high-energy guy I
can be like okay well how can I make how
can I be myself but also try to make it
you know the best thing that I can do or
whatever so it seems like you use pauses
we almost tipped to to the punch line
and like push us over the edge with it
does that make sense like in the timing
of your pace
like yeah I was trying to pause there
but really sorry about yeah I think
timings a break anything you know my
timing on that joke was off I guess
provider cuz no one could tell us a joke
but that's a bad sign for a joke because
if people can't tell that it actually
was a joke that's anyway yeah no I think
appositives are important assembly
something you figure out over time like
how you deliver and where to pause and
pause before the thing cuz you draw from
real life and it seems like there's
moments where you could go further but
you're just like I don't work at the
Apple Store anymore and it's like and
then like people always ask me questions
and you just move on you could go into
like somebody asking you a question
yeah actually do you have some other
things about the Apple store no okay but
they weren't part of that specific set
that I taped I was being the side for
the thing so yeah it's like I don't know
it's every shows a little different so
it's like kind of funny of that and then
it's like I guess I put that out so it'd
be weird like I guess I could do the
other parts of the that joke on a
different thing but I have more time but
yeah like it fit on a loom or something
I don't know but yeah it's like you just
figure out what works and but is that
something that happened in your life
we're going to Apple stores and yes
you're like this is ridiculous happened
a couple of times where people asked me
for help
and I was like be like I don't work here
so it's where most material is like
something happens and you're like oh
that could be funny and then you try it
on stage yeah I just tried to like
anytime I think of something that I
think is funnier if something funny
happens I think could be funny to talk
about I just try to like write a note to
myself so I remember and then maybe try
to flush it out later and then I think
free writing helps a lot so yeah a lot
of times it doesn't feel like it's going
anywhere when you free right but then if
you do that I think it puts you in the
right mode as like a writer and then the
today you're thinking as a writer and
you as things happen you immediately
have in your mind like a funnier take
than you probably would have if you
hadn't done the for you so stuff like
that I think I don't do it often enough
I feel like but when I do and I think it
doesn't help the writing process and
free write about something that happens
in the morning and then let it ferment
yeah yeah I think you're free writing
about anything that happens to you helps
and then even if you don't think you're
getting stuff out of it at the time I
think it gets you in a good mindset the
rest of the date I think of things as
they come to you and come up with stuff
based on what's happening and I saw you
also record your sets you record all of
your self yeah I try to record them all
and then I try to listen to them I don't
always listen to all of them but yeah I
feel like it does help the more often I
can to like listen especially to the
newer stuff then you can kind of figure
out what worked because it's all kind of
a blur sometimes once you're up there
you're just moving on to the next joke
and you can't really think about it too
much but later on you can go back and
see like oh that line worked or that
didn't work or that kind of worked but
maybe if I reworded it it would work
better so yeah it's just you know just
even seeing how it went and what I mean
to bore you with your own creative
process will it will land this plane
I appreciate your plane he didn't act
out right some that's a you to improv
training finally there's a plane where
did you hear that it's not like a plane
was landing above it it did there is a
bump up there's some kind of noise
upstairs something Crazy's happen
turn up well let you turn down or
whatever you got to do man but before we
get out of here is there anything else
you want the world to know I just want
you guys to know that if you watched all
this you have too much free time no I'm
just kidding uh thank you for watching
please support hot breath by their water
listen of the watch the podcast or
listened to it and also
yeah like he said please check me out on
season 11 of Wilding out coming out
every Thursday starting July 12 and
we're also taping as season 12 in
Atlanta starting this weekend I don't
know when this airs but yeah so check so
check that out and then in the fall you
can see me in DC and a bunch of college
shows and some of their shows
so check Jacob Williams comedy calm and
you can find me on Instagram and Twitter
at Mr Jenkins and on Facebook comedian
Jacob Williams comedian Jacob Williams
thanks for being on hot breath Thank You
comedian wait no that's gonna be the
thumbnail oh the thumb was us pointing
was us pointing at the oh no that was
good is there a way to get a also a
photo now that I could post now or is of
this of this of us talking to the air
now Oh like a photo with that like
somehow or no or screenshot of the video
okay don't worry about the video
no where's our still recording yours we
are still recording this is still part
of the podcast this is still part of the
podcast we're gonna be the weirdest
ending of a podcast like talking about
the logistics we started the pie oh is
the podcast ending aren't clear
beginning an end but then it's also the
organic side that you had a reference to
where you just make it happen bro yeah
but then it's like at a certain point
you're its I'll be like walking down the
street this week I'm like am I still in
the podcast I gotta be careful what I
say every day but I think there's a
microphone over there yeah there is
we're being recorded everywhere so why
isn't a bit Truman Show might as well
get likes on and check it out yeah we'll
figure out how to get you on here buddy
I'm mostly here to promote Jim Carrey's
movie from 20 years ago The Truman Show
it couldn't be more relevant now
absolutely social media do you ever feel
like you are the Truman Show do you ever
get that in terms of being
self-conscious and wearing
people are watching me yeah absolutely I
don't think I'm actually being filmed at
all times for a television show but I do
have some of the paranoia and
self-consciousness that goes along with
that at times all right all right all
right Jacob Williams thank you guys tune
in next time